bonjour je suis un gars vous merci de
répondre à nos questions on assiste à
l'éclatement de l'accord à tunis l opep
les pays de l'opep ont emmené par
l'arabie saoudite au groupe dit non opep
conduit par la russie quelles
conséquences selon vous c'est cette
baisse
2 du pétrole notamment avec la
déclaration de donald trump
vous savez le pétrole c'est un monde un
petit peu compliqué où il ya grosso modo
trois joueurs qui sont importants vous
avez à l'arabie séoudite bien sûr vous
avez la russie et vous avez les états
unis alors l'équilibré rompu il ya
quelques années avec l'exploitation du
pétrole par le multaq du fracking aux
états unis c'est à dire on casse des
roches et on en extrait du pétrole et
les états unis
du coup sont devenus le premier
producteur pétrole de pétrole mondial et
ce qui s'est passé c'est que ça beaucoup
saluent une influence sur les prix ce
qui fait que des pays comme l'arabie
saoudite et même la russie ont dû
baisser leur production pour éviter un
effondrement des cours
est ce qu'il s'est passé récemment sait
que l'arabie saoudite a dit et quand la
russie écoutez je moi là-dedans l'opep
je réussis pas à tenir les troupes c'est
à dire que tout le monde triche et à qui
mieux mieux comment tout ça ils
produisaient plus que leur quota
donc est-ce qu'on pourrait se mettre
d'accord tous les deux pour essayer de
baisser les peu de baisser nos quantités
tous les deux puisqu'on est après les
etats-unis les deux plus grands
producteurs mondiaux et les russes ont
leur ont dit non et c'est une nouveauté
extraordinaire parce que dans le fond
monsieur poutine
il a toutes les qualités du monde c'est
un excellent joueur d'échecs et il
attend le moment de frapper
donc grosso modo ce qui se passe c'est
que mettons au dessous de 50 dollars le
baril le pétrole extrait des etats-unis
par les nouvelles technologies n'est pas
rentable
donc on assiste par l'intermédiaire de
poutine à une tentative de déstabiliser
la production de pétrole aux états unis
qui se passe principalement au texas et
dans l'oklahoma et c'est ce qui est
intéressant dans cette histoire c'est
que bien évidemment comme monsieur train
peu dit que c'est une baisse d'impôts
c'est une baisse d'impôt pour le
consommateur américain ça va sans dire
mais c'est une énorme perte pour les
états qui produisent du pétrole aux
états unis dans le temps quand il y
avait une baisse du pétrole aux
etats-unis quand il était gros
importateur de pétrole
c'était le consommateur américain
bénéficier et le producteur saoudiens ou
aux koweïtiens qui prenait qui prenait
la gamelle mais c'était la russie
l'arabie saoudite vont ils pouvoir
supporter longtemps cette messe des prix
aux la russie ils ont une telle habitude
de prendre des coups dans la tête de
résister que je fais pas beaucoup de
soucis si vous voulez ils ont des
réserves de change absolument immense
leurs monnaies vient de baisser beaucoup
ce qui fait que grosso modo le prix du
pétrole en roubles n'a pas tel à bouger
mais pas tellement que ça le vrai
problème c'est l'arabie saoudite parce
que leur budget a été fait à 55
milliards à 55 dollar par baril et ils
ont déjà des déficits budgétaires
monstrueux et donc si on est à 30 bat la
réalité si vous voulez créer que
l'arabie saoudite qui est un pays
complètement farfelu qui n'a aucune
existence réelle et qui ne marche que
sur la corruption et sur le partage de
la rente pétrolière entre la famille
entre les membres de la famille royale
risque de sauter quoi parce que c'est
leur budget déficit budgétaire
absolument explosé explosé et quelque
part personne ne travaille en arabie
saoudite
tout vient de tout le niveau de vie de
dépend que de la rente pétrolière
merci shanghai d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes le
président du think tank libéral institut
des libertés